charles 48 heures après la fin des
frappes américano britannique en irak
les diplomates représentant les 15
membres du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
tente de reprendre le pas sur les
militaires ils ont été profondément
divisée et mis devant le fait accompli
par les américains il cherche maintenant
et certains l'initiative de la france à
établir un nouveau système de contrôle
international sur l'irak commentaires
bernard lebrun mission difficile pour le
secrétaire général des nations unies
celui qui n'a pas été consulté avant les
frappes se retrouve avec la balle dans
son camp question comment renouer le
dialogue avec l'irak ça ce n'est pas une
question facile pour un lundi matin
et j'avais beaucoup de discussions qui
se poursuivent entre gouvernements pour
dire que nous avons besoin des nouvelles
structures que nous avons besoin de
nouveaux mécanismes d'inspection mais je
ne sais pas ce que cela veut dire je ne
sais pas ce que cela implique je ne sais
pas quel type de structures eas on
sentait
du sourire à la gravité kofi annan ne
cache pas son désarroi avant même
d'entrer en séance premier des cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité à offrir ses services la france
avec trois pistes de réflexion
d'abord le vrai d'urgence pour une nette
amélioration des conditions de vie des
irakiens ensuite associée à la levée
progressive de l'embargo pétrolier un
vrai contrôle financier du pays enfin et
surtout modifier radicalement lun's
comme en faisant en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de présence permanente
d'inspecteurs sur le sol irakien modèle
retenu l'eeie l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie nucléaire en oeuvre en irak
avec des caméras automatiques et se
contente de visite surprise de contrôle
sur le terrain seulement voilà encore
faut-il que l'irak s'ouvre au dialogue
et entendre les offres de paris cela
semble plutôt mal parties
n'ont pas de position
en deux
alors les autres membres permanents
s'active comme ici les britanniques qui
recevait ce matin les allemandes et puis
il reste la grande inconnue de ce
conseil de sécurité que vont proposer
les états unis d'amérique pour l'instant
tout le monde ignore